high in the French Alps a slackline
spans 18 meters across a deep ravine
Kenny ballet begins to make his way
across on a mountain bike suspended over
a 100 12 meter drop
he's the first ever to manage such a
feat a huge achievement it was like
hadn't done falling off my shoulders I
was there and I like it was like like
winning four world championships in in
30 seconds it was eyes it was the best
feeling of my life so far the Belgian
cyclist spent a year training for the
stunt he fell from the slackline often
human is not made for such heights even
if you're attached falling off he's
always scary it's really not natural I
remember when I fell off the first time
I was screaming like a little girl Kenny
belay is one of the best mountain bikers
in the world he was just nine years old
when he entered his first competition he
went on to win one title after another
he spent several weeks every year
training in the costa blanca the Sun is
always shining the air is fresh there's
no pollution here for an athlete this is
the best place to be and to prepare
myself for my for my competitions that's
why I come here in Spain it's a
playground to do all outdoor sports and
I yeah this is this is my life
the sea and the mountains are all within
easy reach here between training
sessions he often chooses a different
sport to relax like stand-up
paddleboarding in his lunch break
but then it's back to the bike
mountain bike trials are his greatest
fashion in this discipline it's all
about balance the rider has to pass
through an obstacle course usually
involving rocks if the riders touch the
ground with their foot they get penalty
points Kenny valet is one the trials
world championship four times and has
topped the international rankings for
over 15 years
Street trials are a popular variation of
this discipline for the streets of a
city become the obstacle course
Street trials is more about creativity
and using the natural urban obstacles as
a playground and just be as creative as
possible and play around jump on
everything you see and then spice it up
with some freestyle tricks and I also
liked doing that a lot Street trials are
perfect for creating videos that get
hundreds of thousands of klicks online
this allows athletes to market
themselves you too Kenny ballet was
ahead of the pack becoming the first
trial cyclist to turn professional in
2003 he's developed his own show and
gone on tour with it visiting more than
25 countries he loves to choose the most
unlikely places for his trials like the
TV tower in the japanese city of nagoya
spectacular images like these are great
for attracting sponsors in extreme
sports dozen you it's a it's almost a
hype to always do things that are crazy
and more spectacular and etc etc but the
thing is people always had these dreams
I mean flying an airplane was impossible
and of course you want to promote your
sponsors in a cool way as well but in
the first place you do it for yourself
and just to even if nobody is watching I
think we would still do it and push our
limits and see what is possible Pillay
is constantly on the lookout for new
obstacles to test his skills right now
it seems like the sky is the limit
we know it may be in 23 years i have
another crazy i do somebody gives me an
idea or an opportunity and then we do
another project but this is not
something you can force and you have to
go with the flow and when the time is
right it will happen and if it doesn't
happen I mean and i'll still be riding
my bike and enjoying life only when the
Sun drops back behind the Spanish
mountains this kenny burrell a finally
dropped back a gear ready to chill for
the evening tomorrow is another day and
another challenge
you